donda or certified lover boy
i think
i like i prefer certified lover boy more
but
there aren't there i think this the
songs that i love on donda i love more
than the songs i love on so if i live
boy if that makes sense like that makes
sense
i love pure souls i love come to life
okay okay part two jail part two like i
love those [ __ ] songs more than i
think i like way too sexy even though
i'm playing way too sexy like five times
a day yeah
like if you take like the top like six
or seven records off of donda's it's
[ __ ] no that's amazing yeah like i ain't
gonna lie i love hurricane i love
[ __ ] that off the grid is crazy yeah
bro but then you play certified little
boy top to bottom and you're like bro
it's undeniable it's it's london hell
yeah what are you kidding me yeah that
[ __ ] slap bro and i'm not even like i'm
not even the biggest drake fan like my
homies are like the drake fans i'm the
one that's so you're saying front to
back
it's undeniable certified lover boy yeah
yeah front to back for sure bro it's
fire what you mean you don't agree with
that i just think it is the most
generic
uh on i just feel like it was the most
uninspired attempt at an album i've
heard in a long time i'm like you know
you played it safe or something i mean
he always plays the safe but that's the
thing bro bro i said i saw you're
playing safe when you're number one i
saw rory say this uh on his podcast with
maul he said that uh somebody he knew
said that it felt like drake was pair
like making a parody of himself
oh yeah yeah and i was like yeah i saw
someone be like uh what was the first uh
mixtape that he put out october's very
own uh what was the it wasn't so far
gone it was before that it was um yeah
come was it come uh what the [ __ ] was
the name of that tape what's the message
i don't know the joke yeah comeback
season actually yeah yeah i heard i
heard like the homies say it was like
basically just repurposed comeback
season and i was like damn that's a
crazy take but no i don't know bro to me
there's no playing it safe when you're
that